somebody who  is a la pillar how much did it help when  you had guys like a future come in and  co-sign like what you were doing  officially just made it better for the  women the women was like a whole future  for messing with Joe  it just makes the eye look better and  that's sad though I was I was a somebody  before future came to say anything but  future put more light on Joe Moses you  know what I'm saying like but it's sad  in your own area where  like promoters didn't open up to me  until future came and start coming to my  my clubs with me or I start I start  thugs start pulling up with me him and  gonna start jumping out of the club so  they like Hey Joe we want to book jomos  for this party this party too because  gonna might show up Thug my show G herbo  might show up Ty Dollar Sign might show  up like bro I've been bringing out the  whole city for years and years at a time  it's only facts like you know what I  mean like I speak facts